so let's say you want to buy the new
24-inch imac because of its incredibly
powerful and reliable m1 chip
or maybe because of its detailed and
color accurate 4.5 k display
or maybe even because of the radical new
design with the white bezels and that
classic chin
but you just have one major problem you
have no idea
which model maybe which color or which
upgrade options you should buy
well that's what i'll help you figure
out in this video because
if you're not careful you could easily
make one of these eight purchasing
mistakes
so before i get into the buyer's guide
portion of this video let's get into the
first mistake that you absolutely must
avoid
you need to know that the base model has
a few limitations like having a 7 core
gpu instead of the full 8
not getting an ethernet port built into
the power supply
not getting touch id on the new magic
keyboard being limited to just
four colors and the biggest one which is
only getting two ports
on the back instead of four now if you
want any of those things you basically
have
two different options number one is to
choose the base model and add things
like the upgraded power supply with
ethernet or upgrade to the magic
keyboard or touch id
but keep in mind that you won't be able
to get the two extra ports if you use
this method
and then option two is that you can
simply go for the 1499 model which comes
with all of that included
but the issue here is that you might not
care about the ethernet port at all
since these imacs come with wi-fi six
which is very reliable
or maybe you don't care about touch id
so it sucks to be paying the extra two
hundred dollars if you don't want all of
those features
and this actually leads to mistake
number two
thinking that the extra two ports on the
1500 model are full speed thunderbolt
ports
because they're not they're simply usb
type-c ports with limited bandwidth
being eight times as slow
but thankfully there's an awesome
solution to this problem which is
perfect for the desktop imac
owc's new thunderbolt hub is able to
take just one
thunderbolt port on the imac and turn it
into one regular
usb 3.2 port and three yes i said three
full speed thunderbolt ports so if you
go for the base model imac for thirteen
hundred dollars and buy this a hundred
and fifty dollar hub
you're gonna end up with a total of four
available thunderbolt ports
and an extra usb type-a port which you
can't get on the higher-end imac models
no matter what price you pay the only
downside is that you don't get those
other upgrades like the ethernet power
supply the touch id magic keyboard or
the extra gpu core
but since the hub is only 150 dollars
you can spend that left over 50
on any of those upgrades and you'll have
four full speed thunderbill ports
or you can actually put that 50 towards
the even better
owc thunderbolt dock which packs a ton
of different ports like three
thunderbolt ports
gigabit ethernet four usb type a ports
an sd card slot and an audio jack which
i would say
is definitely worth it for those who
care about those ports so if you're
interested in either of those you can
use the links in the description below
to check them out
now getting into mistake number three if
you're planning on reselling the imac
later so you can pick up the larger imac
in the future
be very cautious about the color of the
imac that you're buying
for example everyone out there is fine
with silver since it's a classic and
neutral color
but if you're gonna be buying a yellow
imac you're instantly scratching out a
portion of the potential buyers who
think that color would look ridiculous
in a home or an office
or if you're going to be buying the pink
one you're probably going to have a much
tougher time
selling it so if you're planning on
reselling it be mindful about the color
you buy
so you might want to go with something
like blue or silver but then again
if you're keeping it long-term then buy
whatever your heart desires
but bringing us into mistake number four
if you know
for sure that you're gonna be buying the
larger imac when it comes out anyway
then it might just make sense to
completely hold off on this 24 inch imac
and wait a few months for the new one
and if you absolutely need an m1 mac
right now to get you through those few
months
then i honestly would recommend getting
the m1 macbook air
since it's currently on sale for only
900 brand new on amazon
and that model is gonna be much easier
to resell than the 24 inch imac since
it's portable and more popular
getting into mistake number five don't
think that you absolutely must go for 16
gigabytes of ram because
everybody's saying that eight gigabytes
is not enough that's simply
not true because we've ran extensive
testing on our eight gigabyte m1 macbook
air
and it performed impressively well
compared to the 16 gigabyte m1 macbook
pro
definitely not being a huge bottleneck
and although eight gigabytes of ram is
definitely not 16
apple's unified memory is incredibly
efficient so you can get much more out
of eight gigabytes of m1 memory
compared to eight gigabytes of ram on an
intel mac like we showed off in one of
our tests
we even proved that apple's unified
memory is better by completely maxing
out the ram on both an m1 macbook pro
and a windows based laptop and then
showing how the m1
barely slowed down in terms of
performance compared to the other laptop
with traditional ram so i'd say that for
most people
eight gigabytes is going to be totally
fine and if you're worried about the
whole
ssd swapping issues that people claim
the m1 max have
we actually did a full dedicated video
on that
and found that the issues were very rare
and likely due to software bugs with
rosetta 2
which may have already been dealt with
so don't worry about getting
only 8 gigabytes of ram now on the flip
side we have mistake number six
which is thinking that you can upgrade
the ram yourself after you buy it
which you can actually do on the 27 inch
intel imax but that is not the case with
apple silicon max so it is very
important that you buy
the amount of ram that you think you'll
need right away
this is going to be the case mainly for
people who are using or planning to use
high-end productivity apps like xcode
logic and especially photo editing since
those tasks can really eat up a lot of
ram
and if you're thinking of potentially
running virtual machines in the future
like running windows 10 using parallels
as we showed off with our m1 macbook pro
then getting 16 gigabytes of ram is a
really good idea
since you have to dedicate your ram to
that virtual machine but once again
if you're somebody who doesn't do any of
this high-end productivity work
eight gigabytes should be just fine and
you'll be able to spend that extra 200
on something else say extra ssd storage
and that brings us to mistake number
seven you need to be wise about the
amount of storage that you buy
because like ram you cannot upgrade it
yourself
so some people are going to be buying
the base model with only 250 gigabytes
of storage
and then suffering a few years down the
road when they're completely out of
storage
and they can't figure out what to keep
or what to delete but then on the flip
side
somebody's gonna go out and buy the two
terabyte ssd storage model for an
extra 800 and then a couple years later
when they're ready to resell it and buy
something else
they will realize that you won't get
anywhere near that extra 800
for the ssd when they didn't even get
close
to using even one terabyte so the point
that i'm trying to make is be wise about
your storage and the best way to do that
is to look at how much storage you're
using on your current computer
and then order based off of that and
then finally for mistake number eight
consider buying an external storage
drive because you can save
a ton of money and with the imac you
have a desktop setup and not a macbook
so internal storage isn't as big of a
deal for example
this sabrint rocket extreme ssd that we
recommend with 2 terabytes of storage
is only 360 on amazon compared to paying
apple a massive
800 for their two terabytes and since
this is a thunderbolt drive
you're gonna get incredibly fast
transfer speeds similar to what you get
with the imac's internal storage
and on top of that if you end up
reselling your imac sooner than you
initially thought
you get to keep the ssd drive and reuse
it for your next computer
so it's really a great solution and now
with all those mistakes out of the way
let's finally get into the buyer's guide
if you're buying the 24 inch imac as a
reliable computer for casual or family
use
mostly relying on web-based apps or for
internet or for business
schooling stuff like that then i would
honestly just go with the base 1300
model you definitely don't need 16
gigabytes of ram and you don't need to
upgrade to the a core gpu model
and then if you really want the touch id
magic keyboard you can upgrade to that
separately
and potentially even upgrade to a 512
gigabyte ssd
if you have a big family who will all be
using it now if you want a reliable
computer but you're also going to be
using it for some light productivity
work
like some basic video or photo editing
then i would argue that sticking with
eight gigabytes of ram should be just
fine
but you'll definitely want at least 512
gigabytes of ssd
and i don't think that the 7 core gpu on
the base model is a big deal at all
but if you're taking your work very
seriously with professional programming
music production video editing photo
editing or anything else that you rely
on to make money
then i would definitely upgrade to 16
gigabytes of ram and either get the
mid-level spec with the extra usb type-c
ports or buy one of those odbc
thunderbolt hubs for the extra ports
and at that point you should at least be
buying a 512 gigabyte ssd model unless
you can rely on fast external storage
like the sabrint ssd drives and finally
if you're somebody who's thinking of
running
parallel 16 to play games under windows
10 i would definitely recommend
a large ssd for downloading games and 16
gigabytes of ram since the m1 gpu
depends on it
and at that point if you really take
gaming seriously i would honestly just
wait for the larger m1x imac
which should be coming later this year
with a whole lot more performance for
gaming
so hopefully this video helped you make
a decision and if it did consider using
our links down below to order
but if you're still confused comment
down below with your specific use case
and we can help you make a decision
thank you guys for watching it's been
max click that circle above if you guys
want to subscribe and help us reach
1 million subscribers by the end of this
year you can watch one of those videos
right over there and i'll see you in the
next video